[Music]
we can't even find words to express our
indignation we can't tolerate this it's
unforgivable there's almost nothing left
those shreds of dignity that got lost in
the night of Valle Garrety
[Music]
a small Thor for the 15 year old boy who
was told off and humiliated by macron
because he didn't respect the presidency
by calling him Manu I hope in any case
that Makarov thought that less familiar
that been called Manu on the one hand
don't call me Manu on the other the
presidency is implicitly under mine
this is showing that there is not the
two-faced macro this is the same macro
he just has a difficulties making a
difference between the way he was six
years ago what he really is and what
he's supposed to be because he doesn't
really know I mean he's got no training
for this and he just thinks he could
continue being having the attitude of
rock shell Baker and go out and have fun
and then somebody's going to tap all
over his shoulders say don't forget that
you're president of the French Republic
his results after a year and a half are
not good at all he's got bad results
concerning unemployment bad results
concerning criminality immigration I
mean all the indicators are read
practically and at the same time he's
going out doing selfies as if he was
some sort of rock star
you